hydroxy chloroquine versus brême d y
virent la guerre du médicament fait
toujours rage depuis le début de
l'épidémie les études s'enchaînent et ne
se ressemblent pas récemment une étude
menée par des médecins de l'ap-hp a
montré que les traitements à l'hydroxyde
chloroquine permettrait des taux de
sorties d'hospitalisation
significativement plus élevé sur twitter
le professeur out s'est fait l'écho
d'une autre étude américaine cette fois
ci basée sur l'observation de plus de
2500 patients à traiter en phase précoce
qui présente des résultats
spectaculaires sur la mortalité en
revanche un autre médicament semble
susciter moins de débats dans les médias
il s'agit du remdh et y lire le 25 juin
dernier l'agencé européenne des
médicaments a recommandé l'autorisation
d'une mise sur le marché conditionnelle
de cet antiviral premier médicament
officiellement recommandé contre le coc
vivent 19 le 3 juillet soit moins d'un
mois après le dépôt de la demande
la commission européenne a donné son feu
vert à cette mise sur le marché
pourtant une équipe de médecins de
l'hôpital bichat fait état d'effets
secondaires très graves liés à
l'utilisation de cette molécule sur les
5 premiers patients traités au rêve d
hiver quatre ont dû interrompre le
traitement dont deux pour déficience
rénale majeurs ayant requis de lourdes
interventions chirurgicales
cette série de cas de cinq patients
covit 19 nécessitant des soins intensifs
pour une détresse respiratoire est
traitée avec du remdh et civiles mettent
en évidence la complexité de
l'utilisation du rem des civières chez
ces patients gravement malades
le rêve des civières étaient interrompus
pour des effets secondaires chez quatre
patients
le gouvernement américain a annoncé
avoir acquis 92% de toute la production
de rennes dvir par le laboratoire gilead
jusqu'en septembre prochain la france a
suivi le mouvement en vue de sécuriser
l'accès aux médicaments remdh et s'ils
virent sur le territoire national la
france s'est assuré de la disponibilité
de doses suffisantes auprès du
laboratoire gilead
d'après le wall street journal la dose
de médicaments est produite pour un coût
d'environ 10 dollars
mais j'ai les add a fixé le prix à 390
dollars par flacon dont tous les pays
développés soit 2340 dollar pour un
traitement de cinq jours
de son côté le magazine de référence
business insider estime même que le
médicament pourrait rapporter plus de
2,3 milliards de dollars à gillet had
pour la seule année 2000 20 c'est
justement ce laboratoire que le
professeur à omsk accusent d'entretenir
une trop grande proximité avec les
infectiologues français des liens qui
d'après lui pourrait expliquer le manque
d'entrain de ses éminents collègues
vis-à-vis de l'hydroxyde chloroquine le
magazine sciences et avenir a d'ailleurs
mené sa petite enquête
le mensuel à vérifier les déclarations
d'intérêts des membres du collège des
universitaires des maladies infectieuses
et tropicales et il s'avère qu'il y a
une sur représentation de gilead dans
les liens d'intérêts déclaré par
certains infectiologues de ce collège
scientifique sur 114 membres 97 aurait
perçu des sommes de la part du
laboratoire américain contre 71 de la
part de sanofi
le géant français du médicament en
attendant elle les recherches sur le
vaccin ne devrait pas donné de résultats
avant plusieurs mois selon l'institut
pasteur
mais déjà un laboratoire chinois se dit
prêt à coiffer au poteau
européens et américains les tests serait
d'ailleurs actuellement effectués sur
des militaires chinois
l'enjeu est tout autant sanitaire que
financier et on l'aura bien compris
le premier arrivé sera le premier servi